hello Conan O'Brien here we have a
ritual now in America whenever something
terrible happens our nation goes into
shock and hundreds of people like myself
come on television and try to make sense
of it all now it used to be a task
reserved for newscasters and pundits but
over the years it has inexplicably
expanded to include celebrities and
comedians now sadly I've had to do this
too many times whenever there's been an
act of terrorism or a school shooting
but today feels very different
we're rightfully sickened by the
needless killing of a black man named
George Floyd but doesn't feel right for
me to talk about my feelings of sadness
and anger to do that today feels
inadequate and even somehow wrong our
national crisis is that a large and
vital community in our country is in
real pain pain because they do not feel
safe or dignified or seen and most
important of all they do not feel heard
so I'd like to use my very small piece
of television today not to speak but to
listen to someone I respect who knows
what it's like to be black in America in
2020 Van Jones is here and I am very
grateful for his time tonight now it's
in my nature to try and hit one note of
optimism before we begin
but even optimism can feel hollow at the
moment my favorite writer is Abraham
Lincoln and he once told a country that
had almost destroyed itself over race to
strive on to finish the work we are in
to bind up the nation's wounds yet
tragically here we are 155 years later
still struggling to heal that terrible
wound it is taking too goddamn long and
if talking heads like me and everyone
watching any television anywhere tonight
can really listen
maybe we can find out why